Herkese
[Müzik]
merhabalar hoş geldiniz
Bu bir çıkışlı ama aynı zamanda bir
giriştir Sizler açınızdan bakacak olursa
ve yaşam kutularının üzerinde çeşitli
anlar bunlar aslında gir işlerimiz var
Çıkış larımız var yokuşları mız var in
işlerimiz var bir yaşam yolculuğu devam
ediyorum bu yaşam yolculuğunda ne
öğrendiğimiz neye baktığımız nasıl
değerlendirdiğimiz o yolculuğun içinde
olup olmadığımız çok önemli Aslında
yolculuğun içinde olduğumuz zaman Bu
yokuşlar bir yere ulaşmak için elde
etmek için
yaptığımız Çabalar haline geliyor o
zaman keyifli oluyorlar Ama eğer
Yaşamımızın içinde değilsek yokuşlar biz
sadece
zorlayan yıpratan şeyler oluyor inişleri
düşünecek olursak Eğer
yolculuğumuzun içindeysek yaşımızı
hissediyorsak Yaşamımızın içindeysek bu
aslında kolayca ilerlediğimiz dönemler
oluyor yokuş aşağı güzelce ilerliyoruz
Ama eğer
yolculuğumuzun farkında değilsek
Yaşamımızın içinde değilsek O kolay
ilerlediğimiz zamanlar bizim için
tehlike
kontrolsüzlük nereye gidiyorum diye bir
and bu ve kaygı anlamına geliyor Ben de
kendi yaşamında Bu yaptığım gözlemler
birlikte çeşitli çevrimleri keşfetmeye
başladı Yani bir yandan kendi yaşındaki
kişisel çevrimler ama bir yandan da bir
Dünyanın içinde yaşıyoruz ve bu dünyanın
yaşadığı çevrimler de var Toplumsal
olarak yaşanan çevrimler var küresel
olarak yaşanan çevre
ekoloji ile ilgili çevrimler var
Bunların içinde bunları da fark
ettiğimiz zaman o daralma hisleri
açılabiliyor nerelerde çıkışlar var
bunları görmemiz daha mümkün hale
geliyor Ben de Bu bağlamda Çevik yaşam
diye bir yaklaşım geliştirdim Çevik
yaşamın detaylarına çok girmeye vaktimiz
olmayacak Muhtemelen ama oraya olan
yolculuğu tarif ederken sonda o İrem
şeyi başlangıçta da söyleyeyim Çevik
yaşamın tanımı şu
kendini
ortamda ilişkilerini
kullandığım yöntemleri görerek
bunları görmek için bakarak ve bunlar da
ufak ufak değişiklikler yaparak yani
kendimde ortamda ilişkilerimde
kullandığım yöntemlerde değişimler
yaparak
değerlerine uyumlu takvimine bir yaşam
sürmek Aslında Kaygımız bu değil mi yani
Yaşamımızın Bize huzur vermesi pat min
vermesi zenginlik ya da fakirlik olması
önemli değil sağlık ya da hastalık
olması önemli değil mutluluk yazı üzüntü
olması önemli değil bunlar Çünkü sürekli
olacaklar hep olacaklar herhangi bir
yaşam sadece oğlum ben bunlardan ya da
sadece olumsuz Duygulardan ibaret değil
sadece genişlik the sadece darlıktan da
ibaret değil ama her birini olması
gerektiği gibi yaşayabildiğimiz de
değerlerimiz de uyumlu olduğunda o zaman
binerken de padmini olabiliriz üzülürken
de tatmin olabiliriz ama bunun için
kendimi ve ortamla ilişkilerimi
kullandığım yöntemleri anlamam Tanımam
lazım Ben böyle biraz kendi
yolculuğundan bahsedeyim farkındalıklar
nasıl gelişti kendi yaşamında ne gibi
değişimler dönüşümler yaşadım Öncelikle
kariyer olarak veri alanında çalışmaya
başladı yaklaşık
21 22 yıl önce
sorgulanması
raporlanması data bezi olarak yönetimi i
o zekası sistemleri derken
Bugünlerde daha herkesin duymaya
başlamış olduğu makine öğrenmesi Yapay
Zeka gibi konulara kadar geldi duysa
böyle bir teknik kariyerimi oldu Şu anda
da işte 2019'un başından beri bir
teknoloji önderi firmalardan birinin
sponsorluğunda Yapay Zeka Akademisi diye
bir program yürütüyorum ve bu alanda
2500 şu anda kişiye uygulamalı olarak üç
ay süren çalışmalarla makine öğrenmesi
konusunda yetkinlik kazandırıyoruz ama
çok kritikli olduğunu fark ettim bu
dönemde de 21 22 yıldır aynı alanda
çalışıyor olduğum halde Yani Kariyerim
veri üzerine ver üzerine Çalışmalara
devam ediyorum İki yıl aralıklarla
baktığım zaman
yaptığım için çok ciddi anlamda da bu
düştüğünü gördüm yani görev tanımı
sürekli değişiyor dönüşüyor
yaptığım iş Hatta Uzunca bir süre aynı
şirkette olduğum halde
ünvanım aynı olduğu halde içeri ciddi
anlamda dönüşüyor İşte bu dünyanın
çevrimleri ile ilgili biliyor veri ile
ilgili bu değişiklikler Aslında dijital
dönüşümü tetikleyen konular oldu Şimdi
artık hepimizin Yaşamının içinde yani
ben bu alanının öncülerinden Öncü
sektörlerinden kollarından birinde
çalıştığım için bunu daha uzun süredir
fark ediyorum ama artık her alanda O her
mesleği her kariyeri her şirketi Her
ülkeyi çok hızlı bir şekilde değiştiren
dönüştüren bir dijital dönüşümü karşı
karşıyayız mesela kariyerler olarak
baktığımız zaman artık geleneksel
kariyerlerinin bile tanımları çok ciddi
değişiyor dönüşüyor mesela öğretmenliği
düşünün öğrenciliği düşünün uzun
zamandır alıştığımız şeylerdir Bunlar
Senelerdir aynı şeyleri yapıyorduk
ediyorduk falan ama coronanın dışta
dönüşümü daha da hızlandırması ile
birlikte gördük ki artık öğretmenlikten
anladığımız şey de bir hayli
farklılaşmaya başladı aynı şekilde
öğrencilik anladığımız şey de
farklılaşmaya başladı duysa temel
tanımların bile artık oynadığı değiştiği
dönüştüğü bir dünyadayız
ve endüstri mühendisliği ve Mühendislik
yönetimi Master na ardından veri alanda
başladım kariyer Böylelikle beni dijital
dönüşüme doğru getirdi sürecin içinde
zaten teknik kişilerden çok iş
birimlerinden satıştan pazarlamadan
satın almadan finansman argeden
üretimden insanlarla daha çok çalışmaya
başladı meve Dolayısıyla bu teknik
konuların dışında
şirketler insanlar yaşam bundan nasıl
etkileniyor nasıl dönüşüyor Ona bakmaya
başladım bu şöyle bir sürece getirdi
beni Kız Teknik konuların ötesinde
sosyolojik olarak bu nasıl bir
durumdayız acaba tarihte bunun örnekleri
olmuş mu buna bakmaya başladım ve ikinci
lisans olarak sosyoloji 3. lisans olarak
da tarih okuduk o orada kültürel Evrim
diye bir kavramla karşı karşıya geldim
kültürel evrimi anlamadan günümüzün
dünyasıyla başa çıkmak çok mümkün değil
ne demek evlim şöyle bir dünyaya
baktığımız zaman dünya Yaklaşık dört
buçuk milyar yıl yaşında
ki aklınız yan yani hani zihinde
canlandırmak pek mümkün değil dört buçuk
milyar yıl ve canlılığa baktığımız zaman
tek hücreli canlılar üç buçuk milyar
yıldır var daha büyük organizasyonlar
işte dinozorlar falan Milyonlar Yıldırım
iki ayağı üstünde duran ateşi teknoloji
olarak kullanan taşbalta birtakım
aletler üreten
insansılar a baktığımız zaman bir kaç
milyon yıldır dünyada lar ve bugünkü
insan gibi hani öp kuaförüne götürüp
giysisini giydirip önümüze getirdiğiniz
zaman acaba bu adanalımı sivaslımı
tokatlımı ne giyeceğimiz insan yaklaşık
70 bin lira 300 bin yıldır dünyada var
ortalama 200 bin yıl kabul ediliyor yani
300 bin yıldır bir şu anki fizyoloji
mizle şu anki biyolojim izle genetiğim
İzle psikoloji ve bu dünyanın üzerinde
yaşıyoruz
benim anlamında baktığımızda
çok az değişiklik var artık köyde gördük
salgında gördük koronun evrimini mesaj
ana haber bültenlerinde takip ettik
değil mi İşte giderek daha ehliyle İşte
aslında kendi yayılmasında
kolaylaştıracak şekilde ölümcül azaldı
tek hücreli canlılarda virüslerde Bu çok
daha hızlı bir süreç ama insanda çok az
öne çıkan mutasyon var bu süreçte 200
bin yıldır aynı insan olarak dünyadayız
ama baktığımız zaman çok büyük
değişimler yaşadığını görüyoruz Bu
insanın nasıl oluyor yani bu 200 bin
yılın 100 Evet şu an bir yılında
avcı-toplayıcı olarak yaşamış Ken Bizler
doğanın içinde 50 100 150 kişilik
gruplar halinde
yaşamış Ken özel mülk diye bir kavram
bile yokken Sadece taşıya bildiğimiz
eşyalarla yaşamımıza devam ediyorken Ne
oldu da bunlar oldu bu binalar bu
yerleşimler uçaklar internetler falan
bunlar nasıl oluştu diye baktığımızda
burada teknoloji üretime dayalı
üretimine dayalı kültürel evrimin çok
kritik olduğunu görüyoruz acaba tarihte
Bunlar hangi ölçeklerde gerçekleşmiş
birincisi Neolitik Devrim yaklaşık 10
bin yıl önce insanlar bir yıl genetik
alanında tarımda hayvancılıkta
çok önemli teknolojik yenilikler
yaptılar ve bunların birikmesiyle
birlikte
için Işık bin yıllık bir süreçte Dünya
üzerinde yaygınlaşan bir şekilde
yerleşik hayata geçtik
ama şu anda bireysel olarak hala bunun
sorunlarıyla başa çıkmaya çalışıyoruz
Çünkü Doğduğumuzda avcı-toplayıcı olarak
doğuyoruz fizyoloji miz biyoloji miz
Buna göre ama yaşarken yerleşik yazılım
her şeyi rahatça ulaşabildiğiniz bir
şekilde yaşıyoruz O yüzden mesela
istediğimiz gibi beslenmeye devam
ettiğimizde kendimize kısıtlama
getirmediğimiz zaman obez oluyoruz Çünkü
fizyoloji miz yerleşik yaşam da yaşamaya
çok uyumlu değil onunla ilgili bireysel
olarak da başa çıkmamız gerekiyor
yerleşik hayata geçtik sonra yine büyük
bir teknolojik değişim olarak
yazılı hayata geçiş var İnsanların
yazıyı keşfet bu yaygınlaşmasıyla
birlikte yazının
alacakları hızlı çiçekleriniz
borçlarımız sözleşme lerimiz
kanunlarımız anlaşmalarımız bilgi
birikimimiz yazılı hale gelmeye başlıyor
ve insanlar çok daha büyük insan
organizasyonlarını yönetebilir duruma
geliyor başlar bunun sonucunda gelsin
imparatorlar dünya bir anda şehir
devletler ortadan kalkıyor ve
imparatorluklar haline geliyor çok kısa
bir sürede
sonrasında 3. büyük dönüşümü samta Bu
arada sözlü kültürden yazılı kültüre
geçişle hala bireysel olarak başa
çıkmamız gereken bir şey
konuşmayı çok rahat ailenizin içerisinde
normal etkileşim lerimizi öğreniyoruz
ama yazmayı öğrenmek için okullara
gitmemiz gerekiyor çok da doğal bir
süreç değil yazma onu öğrenmemiz ve
yazılı kültüre adapte olmamız gerekir ve
sonrasında
3. büyük dönüşüm enerjiyi dönüşümlerinin
keşfi doğanın diplerine insanın hakim
hale gelmesi buhar enerjisini şey
lokomotifler için kullanmak dokuma
tezgahlarının Otomasyonu için suyun
enerjisinden yararlanmak sonra
elektriğin keşfi bunlarla birlikte
İnsanlar eski yunan'daki yarı Tanrılar
haline geldiler metal arabalar
içerisinde uçuyoruz mesela uçarak
Ülkeden ülkeye Şehirden şehire gidiyoruz
3. büyük dönüşüm bu ve sanayi toplumuna
ortaya çıkaran şey işte dijital dönüşüm
Bu ölçekte bir dönüşüm yani yerleşik
hayata geçmek kadar
sözlü kültürden yazılı kültüre
geçmek kadar
ve
sanayileşmeyle birlikte Sanayi toplumuna
geçmek kadar
yaşamımızı köklü bir şekilde
değiştirecek bir konusu Oysa biz hala
tutunduğumuz şeyler var Onları çok doğal
olarak düşünüyoruz onları Yaşatmaya
çalışıyor şu mesela Ulus devlet
kavramını Ulus Devlet Sanayi toplumundan
önce yok şu 1700 lerden 1800'ler 1700
1800 lerde ortaya çıkmış ve yayılmış
olan bir kavram ve şu anda da aslında
Ulus devlet pek kalmadı
anayasanın üstünde olur sorarız
sözleşmelere tüm ülkeler imzalar atmış
durumda daha küresel etkiler çok daha
yoğunlaşmaya başladı insanların bağlılık
duyguları Ulus konusunda farklılaşmaya
başladı mesela örgün eğitim örgün eğitim
a Ne olmuş ki hani böyle çok önceden
beri milyonlarca yıldır falan ölmüş yok
canlılığın içinde öğrenme çok yaygın
Soluk alıp vermek kadar iptal leşmiş bir
konu öğrenmek ama örgün eğitim 1820
yıllarda Prusya da Alman ulusunu inşa
etmek üzere tasarlanmış olan bir kavram
ve Aslında Sanayi toplumunda fabrikaya
işçi orduya asker yetiştirmek üzere
insanları kutulamak üzere tasarlanmış
olan yetkinlikleri geliştirmek için
yetkinlikleri köreltmek için tasarlanmış
olan bir şey kalıba sokmak için
tasarlanmış olan bir şey ve günümüzde
çalışmıyor o yüzden de bakanlıklar başta
olmak üzere tüm dünya ülkelerinde itimi
yeniden şekillendirmek günümüz
ihtiyaçlarına daha uygun hale getirmek
dişten imkanlardan yararlanarak Eskiden
yapmanın çok zor olduğu şeyleri şimdi
kolayca yapıp değil ilgili konular var
aynı şekil maaşlı mesaili iş bu da
Sanayi toplumunda ortaya çıkmış olan bir
şey ve gelecekte var olacak mı çok belli
de değil yani bakacak olursak arkadaşlar
çıkışlar arıyoruz Darlanıyorum xia
Corona falan hikaye ekonomik Bunalım
şunlar bunlar enflasyon Bunlar çok küçük
çevreler asıl çok büyük bir çöp çevrem
olarak dijital dönüşümün getirdiği yeni
bir insanlıkla karşı kar şeyiz ve tüm
kavramları yeniden
tasarlamanız gerekiyor ve bu daha önce
gidilmiş bir yol değil Eskileri takip
ederek yürüye bileceğimiz bir yol değil
kendi yaşamımızdan
keşfetmekten başka bir yolumuz yok ve
Ben bunu da yapmak üzere Ben de
olabildiği kadar yardımcı olmak üzere
Çevik yaşamı tasarladım son yarım
dakikaya girerken reklamlar diyeyim
acungil Çevik yaşam diye YouTube'da
aratırsanız Eğer Çevik yaşam rehberi
diye bir oynatma Nissan var oradan Hani
bu adaptasyonu yapma ile ilgili
yöntemler konusunda yardım alabilirsiniz
ve Çevik yaşama giriş kitabına da kitap
olarak takip etmek isteyenler tercih
edebilirler
evet teşekkürler